Hey. Hey. Look at here. Look at here. Oh
my gosh. Heck yeah. Heck yeah.
So, typical Oklahoma. We recently had
some thunderstorms, some rain, and uh we
was in Oklahoma City for a wedding and
it was snowing up there. Just don't
count out April. Well, me and the girls
pull up to the ranch. I noticed a turkey
pin has moved a little bit and I saw
something standing outside the front of
it and I was like, we've got a turkey
out. There's a hen on the outside of the
[Music]
pit. Think that water gap is okay,
Jessie? Yeah, we'll go check that water
gap. This is
Interesting. Bison already been
here. Well, look at
that. I think the water got up just a
tad. This is our normal
crossing. There's some of them cedars I
cut down or somebody cut down.
It's something that you cut down. I
don't know. It depends on where it came
from. I don't think it could be
anything.
Maybe
Yeah. Always a good time to look for
arrowheads. All right.
Well, guess we'll go around
it. We go around it. Oh, yeah. They
come. Well, they're not out. That's
good. Oh, there they are. Yeah. That's
They heard us. Positive is that they're
in here. Oh, they're excited to see us.
Let's hope that fence gap water gap.
[Music]
Hold
[Applause]
on. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa.
Where are you going, guys? Bullet. He's
back here behind us.
What are you doing? Here, Jazz. Okay.
It's not got a limb on your head there.
What are you all jazzed up for? Who's
that? Peter Cole. She
is fiery. Um, Elanor.
Yep. Eleanor is from Seek of
Observation. Did
that limb start to snap or has it always
been that low, doesn't it? It's always
been low.
[Music]
Oh, also got a T-Rex out here, huh?
Well, it's still holding up.
I can't believe it didn't wash more of
the
Oh, did you not lock the gate, hun?
No. Back. Stay in tight.
[Music]
I did clearance the light. How about
that? I do like that.
You like it, too? It's nice, huh? We the
lane. Dad made us a little lane sneaker
route so we can sneak back out of here.
Yeah.
Get her. She's still at it. Oh, look at
her. What?
Well, that's all. Is this Peter Cole
still? Yes, it is.
Chase a
[Music]
She's running. Yeah. What is going on?
She met all the way over here. Yeah,
that's crazy. I saw that. It was weird.
Why the storm? Oh, she ran Eleanor into
the
She can't see.
She looks good. Yeah.
Hello.
[Applause]
Now the wind got for sure.
[Music]
Easy there, T-Rex.
Well, I don't worry about um I like Big
Joe and Elanor together, but Elanor go
somewhere else. And I
That was That was last year, babe. Yeah,
it was last year on the other video.
[Music]
Bullet, get in. Load up.
It's very funny actually.
Bullet. Oh jeez.
Oh my dog. Bullet. Load up.
You're going to stay. Stay. Great. She's
going to come jumping in here and then
But it's pretty interesting because
that's what they probably do to wolves
and coyotes, right? Oh, yeah. They do.
Just they all gang up
and they're not letting her anywhere
near.
Well, Jackie's taking her somewhere.
Well, we'll have to go get
Maya. I want to give a big thank you to
our sponsor today, AG1. So, I do a lot
of my video editing and taking care of
everything early in the morning, social
media wise. It's one of the first things
that I do and something I do before I
drink my cup of coffee as I start with
AG1. Don't get me wrong, I love coffee.
Coffee can sometimes lead to crashes in
the afternoon. AG1 is going to fill in
the gaps with whole food nutrients that
your body needs on a daily basis to keep
me energized and going through the rest
of the day. Or maybe I'm don't get so
hungry in the afternoons or in the
evenings. If so, if you start your day
off with water or any type of juice,
little secret, you can add orange juice
or pineapple juice with your AG1. It's
pretty good. Get a scoop of AG1, throw
it in there with your water or your
juice before your coffee, which I highly
suggest. Shake it up and you're set.
Over 75 vitamins and minerals just in
one scoop. As humans, we have to have a
healthy bacteria in our gut.
So, what comes in your starter packet is
the AG1 can, the powder, also comes with
this really neat bottle. It also comes
with a solid scoop to get all that
goodness. Comes with the liquid vitamin
supplement. And don't forget about your
to-go packets. When you put the powder
in your can, and make sure you keep it
refrigerated, just a little side tip
right there. Get started with AG1 for
less than $3 a day when you subscribe.
Just head to the link in my description
or scan the QR code or you can visit
drinkag1.com/crossimbers and order your
AG1 for less than a cup of coffee per
day.
Here comes Jack.
He just put the brakes on and stopped
grazing right there. Started grazing
right there.
He had to know how to hand it with his
tail up and everything. What are you
doing, bullet?
Yeah,
I'm the dinosaur. You are the dinosaur
right now. Well, since the Big Joe herd
is out in the burn unit and this cover
crop is growing so good and so crazy
right now because the moisture we've
had, uh we decided to let our breeding
bulls and uh some other bulls that we
raised and we are selling uh for breed
bulls. So, these are incoming 2-year-old
bulls, including our knucklehead
blackjack. He'll join the Big Joe herd
eventually again. But this cover crop is
doing so well, we just let them in here
and let them graze some of
it. Meanwhile, the chickens are hanging
out.
[Music]
So, there's the
hen. Have to figure out how to get her
back in. And the panel moved. Wow. We
had
quite the
storm. It moved this entire
panel. Poor
hen. She got out
something. All right, guys. We're going
to try to move you. There's the eggs.
Dang
it. Got two turkey eggs, guys.
I must had a wild party. What What are
you doing in What are you doing in
here? Oh
gosh. You do not belong in here. Okay,
there's the hen. Maybe
she'll come
around. You guys are going underneath
it. Not Not right
now. Jeez. Let's see if I can get this
hen to come around these chickens.
Get
back. Don't want the whole group
out. This is going to be
challenging.
Get back.
Keep coming,
Hen. Keep
coming. Oh, keep
coming. Oh, just a little bit. Dang
it. Take a lot of risk right here. The
gobbler, he can see it.
Oh, come on in.
is about to escape.
[Music]
Come on, Hen. Make your way
around. This is quite the
challenge. All right, so I'm going to
set these eggs down right
here. That gate just
shut. Let's move this pin a
[Music]
little. Have to move this. I got the
wheels up.
So nice this thing rolls like it
[Music]
does chatter
bugs. All
right, we got to get you back in here,
girl. It's your
family. There we go.
Oh, there's another
one. Oh, we got to be easy.
[Music]
Look at there. So, I made a box for him
a couple days
ago. Let's see
if this open for her.
She's hanging out with the
chickens. Keep going around,
hun. She's taking a
ris. She wants to come back over
here. Let me put these eggs back in
here.
Oh, lookucky there. Lucky
there. Oh, don't escape. Please get get
out. Get out. Get out. Get out. Not for
y'all.
Oh dear.
Put that
there. Shoo. Shoo. Shoo. Shoot.
Okay,
Hen. Oh,
yes. Hen is back in. Now, what I want to
do is I got to This needs to really be
in that corner over
there since they're laying eggs
now. At least she's back in here. That's
good.
go ahead and get feed for him. So, I'm
assuming when I came up here first, one
of the wheels was lifted up on this.
Must have got enough wind from the
storms here recently to lift it up and
she was able to get underneath it and
kind of escape like these chickens were
coming in a while ago. It's get
underneath it. So, when you lower these
wheels, see, now it's completely flat.
The wind must have picked it up enough
Now I've got it pushed up against this
trailer right
now. Now it's completely level to the
ground. Must have happened. But she's
back in. And this is so exciting. So,
the question is, guys, do we let the
hens, they just keep laying them? I put
a box in here and they keep laying the
eggs um just out in the middle. And so,
I don't know what to do. Um I need some
help here. Do we go ahead and collect
all these eggs and start the incubator?
Do we do that? Or my intention was to
let them naturally sit on these eggs
once they had their clutches and would
have them naturally and set on them. And
turkeys take 28 days uh to hatch
compared to a chick uh which is 21. So,
need your help, need your guidance. We
do have some incubators or do we let
them have them naturally? It's a chance.
It's a risk. Whatever you do, it doesn't
matter. You're dealing with a wild
turkey egg. I do know that it is hard to
incubate. I've heard that. So, anyways,
you guys let us know what you think. So,
why we kept these guys was for this
right
here. We wanted to keep these three
hands and four toms so that we could get
lots of these right here. We could hatch
them out, raise them up till about 3 or
4 months old and then let them all go at
the ponderosa. We wanted a larger flock.
So, that was the whole point of it is
right here. And it's so satisfying to
see this and so exciting to see it as
well. Next stage is probably incubation
more than likely because the hens aren't
setting. I want to give a big thanks to
AG1 for sponsoring today's video. You
guys can go to
drinkag1.com/costimbers or check the
link in our description here. Thank you
guys for watching. We'll see you guys
soon. We're going to keep on buying
ranching and turkey ranching.